des représentants de m
sa vie n'est pas celle portée par une
économie de marché il ya la communauté
internationale avec toi la russie attend
de voir quel contexte
une grande première dans l'histoire de
l'ex démissionner mais qui continuera
d'exercer un rôle politique en tout cas
le 10 kg et de l'eca lui en donnera les
moyens matériels en match on conservera
s'installèrent de 4000 euros par mois
mais nous resterons à sa disposition
il pourra continuer à employer de
nombreux collaborateurs
des détails qui ont été précisés par
boris
il retrouve tout seul pétards et c'est
un droit qui est la marque des grands
chênes à ma connaissance elle n'est pas
là
chacun joue de l'accumulation dans les
derniers partagé par la foudre le 1er
mai 90 normal
l'inter dans un même temps l'économie
d'abord la préférée de gorbatchev la
réforme annoncée et différée reporter
sans cesse l'ancien système de
distribution est détruit mais parfois le
remplacer chaque cavalier seul
l'exaspération des nationalismes géorgie
azerbaïdjan pays bas lors bacio qui peut
gouverner par la peur qu'avec la rue
incapable de comprendre son application
d'apparatchiks le port fait irruption et
nationales à trois périodes ouvert la
voie à la région
la popularité des cris d'enchaîner
finasseries orbi magna à l'intérieur il
favorise la démocratisation de la
pressée de circulation émergent en sus
calibrer le débat démocratique lors d'un
choc se rend à l'étranger
il est l'avocat du désastre et à limiter
la caution de l'engagement financier si
dental mais pire ses dernières cartes il
le serait trop hasardeux sur la cour
elle d'un char au mois d'août et la
corde
ça donne une zone euro allison
explications de brice il prenait le
contrôle sur soi mais l'armé nucléaire
de la critique première rotative rassuré
quant à la chaîne américaine cnn le
bouton nucléaire passe aujourd'hui le
contrôle du président de la russie qui
est en notre pouvoir avoir le prix ne
sera pas seul aux commandes détient
dorénavant les codes secrets permettant
la guerre qu'il possède à la récitation
très insistants et la bélarusse a
accepté de verser ses draps d'amérique
ne veulent pas abandonner leur droit de
regard sur les 30 décembre prochain la
4e république concernées elles
décideront alors tout le monde en
l'espèce ce droit de regard
plusieurs à l'économie américaine
on sait déjà qu'il te reste trois
rédactions pour les conséquences de la
disparition de ce qu'est la vie à la
maison blanche après une conversation à
la place de michael dorman leurs
partenaires pendant pendant moins
longtemps et demi par l'hymne le matin
pour le remercier de son écran quelqu'un
peut maintenant être rassurés par leur
président la valise dans les cotes de 38
ans pour a déjà changé de mains tendance
eux vous parlera temps de la dépendance
élevée d'une simple lettre le parisien
général de section
la fédérale 3 derrière les celui de la
fédération pourrait vers toi toujours
dans les rues de chacun
les combats sont frileux parler comme ça
sous les bombardements
alors ni alex une journée de perdue loin
de leurs familles
58 ans est imaginaire m
la guerre de la compréhension
essentielle dans la capitale 34 accordé
par des dramatiques
la récession
il ya d'abord la tracter trois
meurtriers prime économie très bien les
péripéties de la paris
l'interpellation l'accusation partie
contre peer
l'homme un iranien est recherché par la
force pour complicité présumée dans
l'assassinât de chapour bakhtiar ce que
dément l'iran l'iran qui affirme au
contraire diplomatique et risque de
compliquer la positionnement succès pour
la visite pour contraindre heures du
matin la capitale iranienne
une grande première
c'est toute la nation
martelly
je connais les témoignages de la
reconnaissance personnelle pour le
travail